that how important is the physical
aspect in this tournament and in this
format and in general in chess
I think it's very important
not only in this tournament but in
in general and I think what has helped
me
a lot
during the course of the tournament is
that I've gotten in in better shape I
was a little bit
sick at at the start I had a
cold I didn't feel so good and I
couldn't
um couldn't exercise and I've been
feeling progressively a little bit
better physically as the tournament has
gone along so that has certainly helped
me and I think yeah in general for
search tournaments
um
physical form and
and nerves which are often
fairly um
correlated are
hugely important